- Dario, Dario, Dario,
let's talk about this.
Let's talk about...
I'm gonna retrieve that later.
(upbeat music)
- Hi, my name is Dario Smith.
I am a men's personal stylist.
- I was just asked to describe my style
and I don't think I
have a good descriptor.
Uh, Target.
- Keith dresses like if
Lurch from the Addams Family
got lost in Old Navy.
- Keith has like four blue button downs,
that he wears constantly.
Like Doug Funny's closet, you open it up
and it's just the same shirt.
- I like blue squares so like,
lots of little blue squares.
A few big blue squares.
Really big into blue squares.
- He almost looks like
one big swatch of blue.
Blue shoes, blue jeans, blue button down.
- Keith also always wears the same shoes.
It's like every day, same blue shoes.
- Having clothes for different things
was never something that I did.
I slept in the clothes
that I wore that day.
That's just how I grew up.
- I think I have a pretty
good fashion sense.
It's getting better.
- Zach, is a little like an old cat lady
trapped in a teenage boys body.
- Half the time I look at him, I'm like,
"How's this appropriate
clothes for the workplace?"
- I like to allow at least
one item in what I'm wearing,
express a sense of colorful personality.
- Even though I love his undershirts,
I don't think it's
necessarily the sexiest thing
you can wear when you're
a single guy at a bar.
- [Zach] One thing I
think I struggle with is,
how to mix and match.
- Zach is little all over the place.
Sometimes he looks really cool.
Sometimes he looks like a child.
- I basically just allow
the women in my life
to dress me.
- I've never had a stylist.
Basically I've had the same haircut.
Same kind of style my entire life.
- Ned's fashion is Steve Carrell,
in the 40 Year Old Virgin.
- He's preppy, casual, white guy.
- I typically like to
keep things conservative.
- I think he likes to have
a level of professionalism.
So, he's very muted.
- I wear Polo shirts almost every day.
But I guess that's not good enough.
- I feel like Ned is very
close to looking like
a dad before he becomes a dad.
- I get uncomfortable
if I wear super flashy
or edgy things because I'm like,
"Who does that?"
Well, Eugene does that.
- I like to think that I take risks.
Overall I would say I'm
a conscientious dresser.
- Eugene has a great
sense of how to marry his
personality into different styles.
- Future sex space ninja.
What does Eugene not wear?
- He wears everything from sweatpants
to a full on suit.
- We'll talk about what we're wearing
and we all agree on a casual look
and he shows up in a fucking suit.
- If Eugene was a Spice
Girl, he'd be Posh.
- I'm just excited to see what part of my
personality I have yet to explore,
through wardrobe.
- I first start with a consultation.
What would you like your
clothes to convey about you?
- Oh man.
Is that the question you're
answering when you put
on clothes in the morning?
- Yes.
- That I have my shit together.
The opposite of a hot mess.
- That I have a sense of adventure.
- That I'm nice, funny, personable.
But also simple.
- I would love for people
to think that I'm cool
based on the way I dress.
- Who would you say is your style icon?
- (exhales deeply) I don't know.
I have so many.
- (exhales deeply) Yeah.
- David Bowie.
- Oh gosh.
- Will Smith from Fresh Prince.
- (stammers) I can't think, I don't know.
- My mom.
- Or the first person
that comes to your mind
when you think of a well dressed guy.
- Eugene. (laughter)
- What would you consider
an insecurity of yours
when shopping?
- Have to look at the sizes
and then look at the style.
Rather than look at the style
and then find one in my size.
So, I feel like beat down by shopping.
- Honestly, I think a lot
of it just comes down to
confidence and I'm put
together and I'm fine
but I don't think that my outfit is sexy.
- The first thing people
saw when I was growing up
was Asian.
There were a lot of negative stereotypes.
What my mother could control
about how people perceived us
was through fashion.
- My biggest insecurity is
that I don't like wearing
things that are outside the box too much.
Honestly, Dario most of the
items in my closet I don't like.
- How about we go look
at your closet now then?
- How 'bout it?
- [Dario] We then go
through a closet purge.
- So, you wanna see my closet?
- Yeah, let's see what we got here.
- These are all of my clothes
but these are the ones
that I wear exclusively.
- The bulk of what I wear, day to day,
is this.
It all matches. (laughs)
- I would love to see
what you consider pieces
that you've purchased
that you've yet to wear.
- Oh, wow.
- Is the shit that you throw up here,
shit that you wear?
- No, never.
- I sometimes wear that one.
Damn it Dario!
This is not fun!
- Let's see your sock collection.
So, we're gonna take
all of your white socks
and dispose.
- What, what?
- We do have a video from your fiancee.
- I would love for Keith to
get more of a professional
looking everyday outfit.
He'll have a button down
that he really likes
but then the has a super old belt.
And dirty gym shoes.
- You can definitely
have a few more options
that help these colors pop.
So, you're not so blue all the time.
- And I want him to think he looks cute.
Because I think he is.
- I think you're a really fun guy.
I think your clothes don't
quite portray that yet.
- If I find a shirt that I
like, I just buy two of them.
Monday, Tuesday, Wednesday...
- When we go out, he'll wear like a blazer
but I have to really encourage
him to wear a blazer.
- Let's move to your suiting.
- My favorite suit, this dark blue one.
Matched with this pink shirt.
- He doesn't go shopping
and he just needs more clothing,
so that your suits don't feel
like a really special thing.
- Do you ever add a pocket
square to this outfit?
- No. No.
I almost laughed out loud when you said
pocket square.
- I just think a lot of
the time I just end up
going back to what I know works.
I mean today is a classic example.
I didn't want to think about my outfit.
- Do you feel like you sometimes
just throw things together?
- By your tone, I think
you think I do. (laughter)
- Why does your outfit now work?
- Fuck Dario, that's a good question.
All right, so my basic is just like,
making sure things don't clash.
- What would be your version of clashing?
- The outfit you told me that worked.
- That would be clashing?
Why would that be clashing?
- These are both kind of red.
- Do you think your hat
clashes with your outfit?
- No.
- Why?
- Because I think that...
- I think you have a lot of great options.
It's just a matter of
pairing those to where
they're most effective.
To helping get dressed a little faster
and a little easier in the morning,
is having a bit of rhyme and reason
to your wardrobe.
- Yeah, this drawer's a nightmare.
It takes me forever to
find a matching sock.
- Here I have the underwear.
Here I have ankle socks.
Here I have workout socks.
And over here are all my dress socks.
There are definitely items I've bought
that I don't wear often
because I'm maybe a little self conscious
about it being too, editorial looking.
A lot of people, maybe
have had the fortune,
of kind of going through
life not necessarily thinking
about how they look.
So, every choice I make with
clothes has led to this point
of seeming like a confident person.
- Your confidence is pretty
much what sells your outfit.
Your outfit doesn't sell your confidence.
- I'm ready though, to see how I look like
in something that's
not safely fashionable.
- Something more avant garde
and a little bit more androgynous.
- Yeah, that would be totally new to me.
- So, I think we've thrown out about half
of your closet now.
- Yeah.
- I would say we start shopping.
Don't worry you're in my hands.
I promise I'll take care of you.
- Okay.
- [Dario] Pinky swear.
- Pinky swear.
I love it.
- From the closet purge and consultation,
I was able to develop a look
that I felt they were confident in.
But a more stylish version of themselves.
Fashion is an art form.
Dealing with apparel, your style,
is how you marry that fashion
with your personality.
(men cheer)
- Look at that dapper man.
He looks like more powerful when he walks.
- [Ned] Keith never wears sweaters.
- [Zach] Where did these shoes come from?
Those socks are not white.
- I'd let you marry my daughter.
- I love that jacket.
- [Eugene] That suit jacket is
basically his shirt elevated.
- [Zach] Yeah.
- [Ned] That's right.
- He actually looks like a host now.
- [Ned] Bob Barker me all over.
- [Eugene] He looks like a Ken doll.
- I'd dress you up and
put you in my dream house.
- Okay.
- [Eugene] Yeah.
(upbeat music)
- What!?
(men cheer and laugh)
Damn Zach!
- [Keith] It's all he's ever dreamed of.
- I want these clothes.
He doesn't look single as fuck,
he looks hot as fuck!
- [Eugene] I've never
seen Zach look that hard.
- [Ned] Like I'm a little intimidated.
- Oh yeah, I wouldn't talk to him.
He's too cool for me. (laughs)
- He's too cool for me.
- [Eugene] I've never see Zach in anything
but the same glasses.
- [Ned] He's the bad boy.
- [Eugene and Keith] He's the bad boy!
- I'm the bad boy?!
- [Men] You're the bad boy!
- Look at him.
- Don't hop, no.
- [All] Yeah!
♫ Hard hard hard I ball
hard in this mother
♫ I ball, I ball, I ball hard
♫ What's up, what's happenin' ♫
- Whoa, that tie!
Oh, that tie's beautiful!
- I love the little touches of red
and the pocket square it's really vibrant.
Now he looks like an Edward.
- Yeah.
- [Eugene] Before Ned
looked like he was on a boat
but now he owns the boat.
- [Zach] He owns the
entire fucking marina.
- This feels like something he
could wear to work for sure.
- Sorry ladies, he's taken.
It is worth pointing out,
you should kind of dress like Eugene.
- Actually, I think he's
dressed better than me.
(upbeat music)
(men cheer)
- [Zach] I'm confused
but it's working on me.
- [Ned] Is that a lady's skirt?
- [Zach] It's just a skirt.
- [Ned] Well, now it's a men's skirt.
- This is like how we're
all gonna be dressing
a hundred years from now.
I'm not there yet.
- [Keith] But I'll be honest,
it's not a stretch in my imagination
to see Eugene wearing this.
- You're saying this
isn't avant garde enough?
- This is not avant
garde enough for Eugene.
We can go harder.
- Let's go harder!
(trance music)
(men cheer)
- This is awesome!
Oh wow!
- Yes, slay!
- [Zach] You look like an anime character.
- Like a future western detective.
- [Zach] I've never seen you
attempt something like this.
- [Keith] There's a
whole sheep on this man,
look at that coat.
- It takes so much confidence
to be able to pull that off.
He exhibits a power.
- Clothes almost became therapy for us.
I was a little bit afraid of what I would
end up looking like.
What a hot nerd.
It's like dapper but it's
totally still casual.
- The shoes that Keith
is wearing, he actually
already owned.
Which looks really good on him.
- You own these?!
- Why don't you wear them more often?
- Because they outclassed
all of my other clothes.
Apparently I already have enough clothes
to make a good outfit in my closet.
I just didn't know how
to piece them together.
Guys, I think I want better socks.
(men cheer)
I want better socks.
After seeing this, I'm much more inclined
to try to look like this all the time.
Because it's looks really good
and it really isn't that
much more difficult.
- Look at the new you.
- Fuck!
I feel way cooler and sexier.
- As in, I'd fuck me!
- Yeah.
I'm miserable thinking about having
to dress myself tomorrow.
Would a Snoopy watch go well?
Or would it ruin the whole thing?
- Coco Chanel quote,
"Before you leave the house,
"take one thing off."
- This is the first time I've
seen you wear your Yeezy's
and they actually match your whole outfit.
- I don't, what are, why are...
What are Yeezy's?
- Now my personality is the quirk.
As opposed to wearing the quirk.
It's amazing to me how clothes can change
the way people perceive
you so dramatically.
- Look how stylish I am.
Hi, my name's Edward.
Man, I need to join the sales team!
(men laugh)
Look at this, I'm wearing a pocket square.
But I love it.
I am a guy that's really on top of my shit
and so my wardrobe should reflect that.
- Ned, had actually been
buying the wrong size suit.
- I had been buying
things too big for years.
Made my butt look good.
(men agree)
- I want to get married to you now.
- Oh well...
My wife would think I look
freaking hot right now.
It was tough at first to
become critical of my style
but I feel like I've emerged,
looking like the best version of myself.
- Ohh my God!
Whoa!
I feel great!
I feel like it's
invigorating this side of me
which is really creative.
Really weird.
What even is this?
- That is actually a jumpsuit,
zipped up halfway and then
tied around your waist.
- You look like a deleted
scene from cowboy bee bop.
- That's the nicest thing
anyone's ever said to me.
- You're welcome.
- I think I went into
this being complacent.
You have to keep challenging yourself
and seeing how parts
of your personal growth
are reflected through your style growth.
I just turned and I almost for a second
didn't recognize my friends.
Everyone here now looks
like fashion models.
(upbeat music)